all we need to do count on one hand the
five things that we want to be really
good about this piece I'm really excited
because the leaf is a board that I've
been wanting to try for the years cuz it
looks like it's essentially snowboarding
anywhere and I've been snowboarding all
my life as a snowboarder I mean it's a
dream come true every snowboard was to
snowboard everywhere they go it's never
impossible but we're gonna get you on
this thing suit you thing yes if I
understand this correctly there's like a
little bit of a learning curve yes it's
kind of if you could take your first day
of snowboarding and compress it to up to
20 minutes to an hour and a half that's
kind of what you're gonna go gosh no
this is our 10 mile faculty use drop
another one in there yes is that just
2/6 old batteries in parallel oh yeah
because you guys make batter so you know
what's up these are 7s 2p to 7x and
adjusting okay and these are the Samsung
cells same as what's in a Tesla so you
put Tesla batteries this is kind of a
secret sauce in the system you know you
can go 360 degrees forever without
wrapping any wires or anything like that
around yeah and it's made out of carbon
fiber is the whole deck carbon fiber the
whole deck is it really no no no this is
the only indestructible side is the
bottom not nearly as heavy as I would
have expected it's the interplay between
the height of this wheel and combination
of these and that's where you get that
snowboard fee for the record both of us
snowboard the first thing that's
apparent to me is two of the wheels are
not on the ground at any given time this
is surprisingly stable
those are like your edges and so a lot
of learning is just feeling where those
edges are okay yeah I mean it's like a
snowboard close your eyes all right so
the last time in snowboarding just push
you a little bit okay a little slow
just imagine
[Music]
you're kind of just going down that
contract now it's interesting because of
our format because you have that sliding
ability you kind of have an e-brake so
you always have breaks so you can go
from 23 miles an hour top speed to zero
in two car lengths
yeah it doesn't turn like a normal
longboard so cuz I was like okay I'm
gonna try to turn so I just kind of get
up on the side that's like it's still
going straight I'm afraid of hitting our
computers you should be
well what do you guys think should we
take this outside man let's do it
use the update we've been working on
this beast script we have the first
complete draft like like I would say
it's officially draft one and that's
pretty cool so v1 final that PDF is now
finally complete
what's the line producer my producers
the pursue system basically budgets out
everything in the film figures out how
much all the different things are going
to cost all the things every single
thing you're gonna need to the dollar
then you can use this as a very detailed
business report to go to investors
currently he's thinking that it's going
to cost at least double what we were
estimating I'd like this script is
definitely bigger than it needs to be
right now there's a lot of big sequences
the filter that our ideas go through
right now is to decide what makes it
into the script or not is it's very thin
I think this is a very good prompt now
that kind of go through and a little bit
more seriously reflect on what do we
need to make this movie and to tell this
story specifically and what is
superfluous with everything from
characters setting locations set pieces
action etc like everything is a
potential target the most expensive
thing is this burning house that's
because the absurd ollars yeah we can
still get to the same plot point that we
get to it the building being on fire
without the building being on fire
I would say I would say like I know this
is kind of an arbitrary way to calculate
or like approach a script or a
low-budget movie all we need to do is
count on one hand the five things that
we want to be really good about this
piece and the rest we have to assume are
gonna be done in a done in a pinch on a
budget
etc first thing that I'm noticing is the
quality of it same motor company is
boosted right
Tesla batteries what else do you need
just do s curves and just kind of lock
into one edge and commit to that edge
and then switch over to the other one I
feel like I'm learning snowboarding all
over again and I love it
you know how when you're snowboarding
and you hop off your edges and when you
come up off the apex of one to get under
the other yeah I like to let go and then
drop down again you have to do that on
these check out my skinny Fork mouth
that's like you have to actively try to
be in the center pretend that you're
trying to balance on just the two wheels
with the four outer wheels just hovering
in the air
thank you
keep accelerating while you're doing
those spins and slides because just like
a mountain pushing you have to keep the
motor going through your turn the motor
takes you through the occasion okay I'm
getting better
this is probably a little bit harder to
learn than any other electric skateboard
I've ever tried however it's probably we
won't rewarding there's such a high
ceiling on skill for this thing as
evidenced by you just casually riding
around doing donuts as you're going
forward
it's all about trying to quiet that
centerline of balance without writing on
the wheels while also spinning perfectly
that's the snowboarding stuff all the
time
now that I've spent a couple hours
actually learning how to ride the board
I feel like I have a pretty solid grass
and it is a lot like snowboarding so
here's a montage and then followed by
some I feel like I'm starting to get the
hang of it and learning curve is real it
took me at least three hours before I
finally got the hang of just carving
back and forth power through that
learning process it will be really
rewarding once you actually start doing
the slides down the street board is not
perfect I do have some major complaints
about the battery system and the grand
scheme of things the battery issues
aren't that big of a deal because it is
still super fun to ride it's literally
like snowboarding on the street I ran
into an issue twice where the battery
completely drained out to zero because
it was still plugged in it doesn't have
the same sort of charging system as any
other board I've ever used where you
simply plug in a cable to the board and
then the board charges on this system
you have to actually remove the battery
unplug both battery cables and then plug
those into the charger apparently the
reasoning for the two battery system is
because it actually splits the large
battery pack into two smaller ones it's
below the regulated limit of a hundred
watt hours allowing you to actually fly
with it on an airplane however what that
means is that you have two batteries
that you actually have to physically
unplug and it's kind of hard to get to
those batteries I just want to mention
that for the sake of honesty and
transparency on this board and I am
definitely sensing that the more I ride
this board the closer to snowboarding
it's getting let's say we have the house
we have a beast
actors actors number one Oh like
seriously like I Nana and and when I you
mean when I when I say this last one
it's like one of the things that starts
on fire okay so the second thing that
starts on fire not gonna be as good that
like the house collapsing not gonna be
as good the interior is so it's like
very very quickly we start to hit this
level of imagine as long as those can
get by without a lot of energy and
resources put into them and still be
good we're okay right this guy plots boy
is here so if we VA's need to need to
but like we can find an exterior
location that fits just fine not have
zero doubts about that the interior as
always managing being at different
building yeah like actually like he's on
stilts or whatever I think he's actually
in there well he's actually moving on
the arms the costume designs like the
faun from Pan's Labyrinth weird animal
lakes or like they go out and like bend
back so it's just a dude cream legs and
like prosthetic legs in front needs like
walk around doing this fun thing they
just pay out the green legs
that's probably will do it or probably a
dude wearing the thing no probably do
just like the arms and sticks and like
the dude Walker I'm hearing it I realize
it's the climax of this of the movie but
at the same time I think focusing on the
emotional elements is way more important
here's the thing like yeah I don't want
any like good too much of this piece but
at the same time I'll be honest the
parts of this piece that I'm least
attached to are the most expensive ones
it's tough so the Beast obviously is a
huge resource and actors are going to
potentially be a little pricey because
we want the best you want to get a good
house we want a good and then the last
thing I would say is
Beavis yeah basically everything else
that's not on that list is we is
basically what we should target back to
work figure all that stuff out make it
so the script is more suitable and then
continue down this path of making this
movie we're gonna record a new reaction
for our character here I got up from
brand that they wanted him to be more
angry and all the other takes I have the
camera motion is not as good and the
energy is just not as good so that's the
best take a half but you make them more
angry
rely on Sam's acting talents to dub in a
new yell are you ready yeah something
like a ah no no let's just warm up here
gonna Mic Check Mic Check let me make
sure it syncs up Mike's a little hot
when the attendant done test is perfect
angry like oh no it's a little hot still
a little bit more test that's perfect
more angry at getting like at losing in
a game a little more energy wait hold on
no I'm work let me just do a quick all
right so it's really clipping still
maybe if I'm just a little further away
like right here ah perfect
all right yeah that was me clipping at
all Wow more angry
yeah than that that's doing he's doing
that yeah getting a sentence like a more
guttural and like ah crunchy peanuts all
right
come on come on no no no no no all right
I think I ruined my voice when Nico
destroyed my iPhone with an arrow
remember that thank you you know what
you guys wanted you're gonna feel what
it's like to have a brush with that he
forfeited burritos to everyone in the
office and today is the day that we
collect yo I do want a burrito I always
want a burrito Wren do you want to bring
down yeah it's a burrito day because
it's been weeks the taco trucks enough
to leave
the taco trucks about to leave we're
gonna lose out on burritos and I just
have to eat my salad or something
oh god please no
[Music]